[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh that's why i wanted to have
pete doherty he's the packers beat
writer for the green bay press gazette
to join us here
pete thanks for joining us is this a
story
yeah um aaron rodgers is a really
really smart guy he's been around a long
time
and he knows how things work and the
impact his words have
and you know he even dropped that hit
last week about his future being
what was it a beautiful mystery i don't
know that's what he said wasn't it
yeah um so he knew exactly
you know what he was doing and there's
some kind of message here what i'm
not sure about and i'm sure we'll get
into is what the message is
but um yeah i think it's a story but
what does he want does he want money
renegotiate does he want out
is he just sort of hey you didn't get me
any help here during the
the draft or help me understand this
pete
yeah i know that i don't i don't think
it's money
i you know they just redid his contracts
at 2018 and 2018 they
did it a couple years early so i don't
think it's that
um it could be
that he just wants to make him score him
they made him squirm last year
you know and he might just be wanting to
make them squirm and you know see how
they like it um it could be
as michael silver wrote i don't know if
you saw that but it could be that
um he wants them to be
more aggressive than they've been in in
adding players and going all in
i think that's you know a dangerous road
to head down
look at the new orleans saints but
anyway that could be his thinking
that he's trying to force their hand
there and just go all in for his last
year or two with the team
or three whatever it would end up being
or it could be that he legitimately
wants out i don't think i think that's
the by far the least likely
but it can't just completely dismiss it
the blame game always happens it doesn't
have to wait too long after a game for
the blame game
so uh where the fingers being pointed at
whom
in lambeau i after the game i pointed it
at the offense
uh that lefleur and you know i mean
rogers those got two guys running it
even though
other people their stars all made huge
mistakes devonte adams drops
a touchdown pass that cost them four
points um
aaron jones one of the what five or six
running backs in the league has a huge
fumble that hands hands him a touchdown
um so there's another there's another
seven so
you know the offense had all the chance
all the opportunities in the world to
to win this game and you know they got
the ball twice
with uh what 20 or what in the fourth
quarter
down five great chance to win the game
and they didn't do it they both times
they went 3-0
so i think it was mostly the offense
just also including that horrendous play
at the end of the
second quarter i mean they why you why
you're not in two deep safeties
you know that will never make any sense
let's go back to
uh fourth and goal two minutes to go
and they decide they're gonna go for the
field goal uh
i had chris collinsworth on yesterday
and he said most
teams most quarterbacks know if it's
going to be a two-down territory it's
third and fourth down
aaron seemed a little surprised that
leflore sent the field goal unit in so
i'm assuming they did not have a
what if scenario here but uh
you know how how who do we hold
accountable for what happened there and
did you agree with what the packers did
uh no disagreed with it you know i've
seen all the
analytics and there's you know even the
analytics
are disagree you know there's all these
independent services i've seen three or
four of them
one of them basically said it was a wash
one of them said
that it was probably the right call by a
couple percentage points another one
said it was the wrong call so
but i just thought it was the wrong call
because um either way you need to stop
so
try to get the points there and then and
roger said that
envelope floorboard said that you know
lefleur called in a play and rogers
wanted to do something else and the
floor said go ahead you know gave him a
signal
go ahead and do it and uh but rogers did
not know that was a
communication failure failure rogers
didn't know that they weren't going to
go for it on fourth down and really
i don't blame him for assuming that they
were going to go for it because
as as i was sitting there as it happened
i just i was stunned when they sent out
the field goal unit i don't know what
you thought but i was
well i i thought i would have had a
different approach if it's four down
territory
i would have run the ball i would have
mixed up something other than going for
touchdowns
and i i think the worst case scenario is
you give the ball to the buccaneers at
the what the eight
seven yard line and then you try to stop
brady there you still need a touchdown
i have aaron rodgers and a chance to
score a touchdown
to take the lead and then try to stop
tom brady
i don't want to give the ball back i'm
not giving the ball back to jameis
winston
i'm giving the ball back to tom brady
and that to me
compounded the mistake of kick the field
goal then give tom the ball
i don't i don't they don't have
analytics for brady pete
you know what i i i think he hit on
something really important there
because there was i think it was two
it's either 220
or 210 left when they were at the eight
so they had a lot of time to run their
normal offense they could have run the
ball if they wanted to they could have
run it three times and two minute
warning plus
as you said you know you don't want to
give the ball back
to brady with all this time left now
they had to be a little careful there
because if you don't get the two-point
conversion
then you need the ball back again so you
got to leave a little time but you don't
want to leave tom brady with two minutes
and their whole offense the whole reason
that they're the number one
scoring offense this year is how
effective their running game was
and how everything played off that and
rogers was just
lethal in play action and they didn't
run the ball
once on those first three plays that
would have been the perfect time
yeah on the early on one of those first
two uh
two downs to run the ball and they and
they didn't i think they got it in the
fourth quarter
the game was right there for them and
they got away from their identity
and they became a drop back team they
looked like the mccarthy teams in the
last few years where it was
aaron drop back and run around and make
a play
yeah i got to have the ball in the best
players hands
i just i just have to i it doesn't make
any sense whatsoever to go hey
we're going to let tom brady have the
ball and i'm going to
count on my defense to shut him down i
don't like those odds
at all and i still got to score a
touchdown but uh you only have seven
months uh to uh
kind of think about this pete you know i
can't imagine
that winter has gotten a little bit
longer there and uh man
next season can't come early enough you
know i'm uh i'm gonna
i've gotta write i'm gonna have to
address this in a column later this week
and i can already tell you what the
first
line's gonna be and it's gonna be the
circus is back in town
because this is this is in its own
different way
this is brett favre talking about
retirement and all that stuff
all over again oh boy no boy
well aaron won't end up in minnesota
though
well you never know i mean i really i i
mean i still find it hard to believe he
won't be the packers quarterback next
year
but uh i didn't thought think fire would
end up in minnesota but
he got out of the jets who knows
i'm gonna book you for august pete so i
can have you back on and then we could
talk about was this a story
or is the circus truly back in town but
uh
thanks for joining us and uh we
appreciate your time pete
oh thank you for having me dan that's
pete daugherty the uh green bay
press gazette